so schools across the valley are not
letting virtual learning get in the way
of celebrating black history month
democracy prep has several events
planned to honor the important
contributions of african americans here
bianca holman is live this morning from
the school's west side campus with those
details
bianca good morning hey good morning
john
so yeah democracy prep they are
celebrating virtually all month long
celebrating black history month and
matter of fact this week they're having
a spirit week virtually and one of the
days
is recognizing historically black
colleges university and of course i had
to represent
showing a little bison love howard
university is
in washington d.c so so glad that
they're able to bring some
attention to historically black colleges
and university and so
for those that don't know democracy prep
is located in the historic west side and
they have a k-12 here at the school
they've got a few other cultural days
planned like a day for traditional
african attire and then in the second
week they've got a talent showcase
and then also art teachers they're
incorporating lessons about key moments
in black history like the harlem
renaissance
we spoke with the executive director
adam johnson and he tells us
inclusion and learning about diverse
cultures are important
he says they want students to learn
about black scientists businessmen and
women and doctors
the impression really is is to help
scholars understand that
the history of black people in america
runs very deep and that we've really um
had an impact on a variety of
of industry in in our country in 1920
now here are some helpful kid-friendly
resources to talk about black history in
your home first you may be familiar with
scholastic.com remember they have those
book fairs well they've got a few
printable lesson plans where you can
learn about black inventors and less
famous
civil rights figures like melva patillo
of the little rock nine
and there's i am homeschool network
that's a website they've got 45
recommendations you can incorporate also
a list of documentaries to watch
and finally the national museum of
african-american history in washington
d.c
they've got a tab for students to learn
about black engineers and inventors
and so of course they also have one
culminating event at the end of the
month here at democracy prep where
students are going to be talking with
local black leaders here in las vegas
making history themselves
reporting live bianca holmen 8 news now
love that bianca thank you very much
appreciate that
so of course we are celebrating black
history month here at eight news now
highlighting local african americans who
inspire others
in our community you can watch our
honoring black history special sunday
february 14th at 6 30 in the evening